[Musique]
est-ce vous qui les observait ou est ce
qui vous regarde les visages de nathalie
dhainaut sont partout ils attirent le
spectateur comme la créatrice elle même
des foules
c'est une ça m'a toujours interpellé des
foules des visages la personnalité des
gens la multitude l'unicité
bon voila et je trouve que on peut dire
tellement de choses en à travers un
visage
[Musique]
j'ai fait des natures mortes aussi j'ai
fait 2 2
des paysages mais ç'a toujours été les
visages qui m'ont qui m'ont plu les
différentes expressions et
le lien qui entre les gens des visages
d'inconnus de célébrité mais toujours
expressif nathalie dayiot travail
d'après photo encre de chine marqueur
bâton d'huile peinture des techniques
multiples mais un point commun le trait
j'ai beaucoup été influencé par
giacometti
évidemment qu'ils travaillaient beaucoup
comme ça part très partouche et je
trouve que c'est vivant c'est vibrant et
c'est vrai que la difficulté c'est de
faire cohabiter le le trait la peinture
c'est une réflexion tout de
de tous les jours d'être et pénétrant
émouvant et parfois des devinettes dans
cette toile arriverez vous à trouver
l'intrus
[Musique]